depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
l'humeur n'est pas à la fête dans cette
boîte de nuit yvelinoise habitué à
accueillir près de 1500 personnes les
samedis soir l'établissement a dû fermer
ses portes en mars dernier à cause du
coc vite 19 malheureusement fermé alors
nouvel an a priori pour le mois d'avril
de l'es21 j'espère peut-être avant mais
pour l'heure tout dépend de ce qui va
donc voilà on n'en sait pas plus on
réclame est pour l'instant totalement
clair pour continuer à faire la fête à
distance la structure située à
l'ancienne a créé des directs de deux
heures sur les réseaux
ils sont diffusés un samedi sur deux et
surtout garder du lien les clients
habituels peut-être vos clientes
viendront quand on reverra
et puis regardez pas les voir il frôlait
car à tours et puis google est vraiment
aussi par laico maison est vraiment le
allied complètement à part le legs du
pacha club
les performances via les plates formes
en lice certains dj indépendante
également opter pour cette option pour
continuer à mixer c'est le cas de dj
ruben l'élan courtois de 29 ans à
l'arrêt depuis le confinement à
participer à un festival en ligne le 30
août dernier aux côtés de huit autres
artistes
on a vu des choses un peu similaires à
l'étranger aux états unis en angleterre
aux pays bas et en france n'avait pas
encore vu de vraiment de vrai festival
virtuel qui donnait une alternative aux
gens qu'ils pouvaient faire la fête
entre guillemets chérémond crs devant
leur télé mais qui retrouvait quelques
perles un petit peu l'énergie musicale
de ce qu'ils avaient pu connaître avant
de confinement
les vidéos ont généré plus de 200000 vue
unique pour cette performance le dj
illinois dû s'adapter à une nouvelle
méthode de travail
c'est un petit peu déroutant parce qu'il
n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de public
devant toi tu es tu es sur une scène de
très haut niveau technique
il ya des festivals et des clubs qui
n'ont pas ce niveau technique donc il ya
beaucoup de light beaucoup de sons
beaucoup de vidéos mais en face de toi
il ya juste des techniciens un peu de
presse
le staff quand tu es habitué à jouer sur
des scènes comme ça mais qu en face de
toi tu es habitué d'avoir 1000 2000
plusieurs milliers de personnes s'était
un peu déroutant que je pense qu'on le
voit un peu sur les images où je suis
pas forcément j'ai pas beaucoup
forcément de présence scénique parce que
c'est vrai que tu sais pas trop comment
de comporter quelle posture adoptée
quand tu es sur une scène comme ça que
la personne en face de toi dj ruben
devra attendre encore quelques mois pour
mixer à nouveau devant un public il
pense pouvoir faire des événements au
milieu de l'année prochaine